if you pay attention to any falcons
games this year you will see plenty of
ghosts in the stands
because there's no nobody at these games
and you know the atlanta journal
constitution had an article earlier this
year that points out the difference
between the announced attendance versus
who's actually there and the gap is
pretty significant and the announced
attendance was plus 70 000 on sunday for
the falcons game against the rams but
any shot that you saw at the stadium
unless everybody was in the bathroom at
the same time
it was uh it was and look bottom line is
it's a business you got to get people
interested in your product and who's
interested in the falcons right now
chris and it's amazing to me that arthur
blank the owner of the falcons
isn't ready to pull the trigger on a
coaching chain especially with three
interim coaches on staff now what he's
saying and what he ultimately does if
they lose to the seahawks may be two
different things that's the power and
the beauty of being the guy who can roll
out of bed any given day and say i'm
making a coaching change but he just
seems like he's being a little stubborn
on this because everybody seems to want
him to do it he's digging in well what
are you waiting for especially when we
know at the end of the year a change is
going to be made yeah it certainly seems
pretty inevitable that the change is
going to be made
what he's waiting for i don't know i
think the thing that i find peculiar a
little bit is just this like going into
the 2016 season the year the falcons
went to the super bowl and blew that big
lead and all that
you know i knew from very reliable
people at that time that arthur blank
wasn't exactly
uh in love with dan quinn and that it
was going to take a playoff run and
probably winning a playoff game for him
to save his job now because they did go
to the super bowl that buys you an extra
year or two certainly and they went to
the you know the divisional playoff game
the year after but last year the wheels
fell off and of course this year they
are totally off um
i don't know exactly what he's waiting
for maybe he just thinks that there's no
need to do it during the season and that
he can still get accomplished what he
needs to get accomplished in the off
season if he just stays the course and
lets dan quinn finish the year
yeah i i just i think that it's not
going to happen it's not in the cards
this year and
you know at some point you got to do
something to try to energize the team
and maybe he realizes
that it's just not going to matter you
know is it a talent issue is it a
coaching issue
and maybe it's just they've they've
signed the wrong guys they've extended
the wrong guys they're stuck with matt
ryan we answered this question yesterday
on pftpm if they would trade him if they
could even find a trade partner yeah for
his 20 million salary next year the cap
charge would be 42 million dollars 9
million more than the cap charge to keep
him on the team in 2020 so they're stuck
with matt ryan they're stuck with julio
jones they just got to find somebody who
can get more out of those guys yeah well
definitely getting more out of them and
you know i think you can question how
they constructed their team a little bit
you know they've let the team kind of
run the team they've let the players
dictate who gets contracts uh they've
been reluctant to make tough decisions
maybe to get rid of guys that
aren't worthy of being paid the way they
should be paid and yet they've given
them more money for what they did do in
the past instead of what they're gonna
do in the future i mean they're mike
they're more top-heavy than the seattle
seahawks were when the seahawks were
going to super bowls and things like
that there's no depth on the team it
seems like seven or eight guys are
making like over 50 percent of the
salary cap and that's just not going to
be a way to get it done ultimately
especially when you have one or two
injuries they show themselves and then
the team falls apart
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports